Everyone knows that work is lame.
Even if you're an actor!
Sometimes all the fame and money that come
with a big role don't seem worth enduring
a cruel director or a miserable film set.
We've already spotlighted a few times where
one scene nearly caused an actor to walk away,
but it's apparently a lot more common than
you'd think.
We explored some maddening moments that drove
their actors crazy in our earlier video, Scenes
That Almost Caused The Actors to Quit.
Well, we're now back with more scenes
that almost pushed actors right over the edge...
Daisy Ridley in Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Starring in one of the most anticipated movies
of the century is an opportunity most actors
would kill for.
But the pressure of filming 2015's Star Wars:
The Force Awakens nearly proved too much for
Daisy Ridley.
The British newcomer didn't have much experience
before J.J. Abrams cast her as Rey, and Screen
Rant reports she almost quit on the first
day when he told her that her performance
during a desert scene felt "wooden."
That note, along with bearing the weight of
the biggest franchise in movie history, almost
prompted Ridley to get on a spaceship to anywhere
far, far away.
Shelley Duvall in The Shining
Shelley Duvall set a Guinness World Record
for her portrayal of Wendy in Stanley Kubrick's
1980 horror classic The Shining – but it's
not a record anyone would want.
The perfectionist Kubrick insisted on 127
takes of the scene where Duvall's hysterical
character uses a bat to fend off a deranged
Jack Nicholson.
By the end, she so was exhausted and dehydrated
from crying that she nearly quit.
She didn't, but the stress of filming the
scene was bad enough that she reportedly began
losing her hair.
Zoe Saldana in Pirates of the Caribbean
Before she landed leading roles in huge blockbusters
like Avatar and Guardians of the Galaxy, Saldana
was just another struggling actress getting
by on bit parts.
She had a small one as Anamaria in 2003's
Pirates of the Caribbean: The Curse of the
Black Pearl, and she said she was treated
so badly that she nearly quit, telling The
Hollywood Reporter,
"It was very elitist.
People disrespecting me because they look
at my number on a call sheet and they think
I'm not important."
It was so demoralizing, Saldana said she even
considered quitting acting altogether.
“Anna Maria.”
“I suppose you didn’t deserve that one
either.”
“No, that one I deserve.”
Mike Myers in Wayne's World
Mike Myers created the character of Wayne
Campbell on Saturday Night Live, and the recurring
sketch became so popular that Paramount wanted
a Wayne's World movie.
Myers wrote the screenplay, and he was especially
excited about the scene where Wayne and the
boys pack into the Mirthmobile and headbang
to Queen's "Bohemian Rhapsody."
But the studio wanted to replace the song
with something fresher and cheaper to license.
Myers thought the Queen song was crucial,
as he revealed on WTF with Marc Maron.
“At one point I said to everybody well I’m
out.
I don’t want to make this movie if its not
Bohemian Rhapsody.
And they were like, who the Fu*k are you?”
“Yeah.”
“I said, I’m somebody that… that wants
to do that movie.
That’s the movie I want to do.”
Both Myers and Bohemian Rhapsody stayed.
Gene Hackman in The French Connection
Gene Hackman won an Oscar for his turn as
New York City police detective Jimmy "Popeye"
Doyle in 1971's The French Connection, but
it almost didn't happen.
A notoriously difficult actor, he often clashed
with director William Friedkin, especially
after Friedkin revealed Paul Newman was his
first choice for the part.
Things came to a head during a scene where
Hackman – dressed in a Santa Claus costume
– tackles a criminal on the street.
Friedkin demanded 27 takes, and Hackman nearly
quit.
Fortunately, he stayed and even mentioned
it in his speech at the Academy Awards.
John Cena in 12 Rounds
Few wrestling stars are bigger than John Cena,
so when WWE produced the direct to video cop
thriller 12 Rounds in 2009, casting him as
the lead was a no brainer.
Although his day job is to battle hulking
beasts in the ring, Cena apparently isn't
fearless.
One scene called for his character to rappel
down a skyscraper and dangle mid-air from
a rope.
But Cena revealed later that his severe fear
of heights triggered intense anxiety and he
considered walking away before he ever got
up there.
Mary Elizabeth Mastrantonio in The Abyss
The dark, claustrophobic sets and constantly
gushing water made for some difficult days
on the set of James Cameron's 1989 sci-fi
flick The Abyss.
But one day in particular stands out for Mary
Elizabeth Mastrantonio.
For a scene in which her character's estranged
husband administers her CPR, Cameron asked
co-star Ed Harris to frantically slap Mastrantonio
as she lay motionless on the cold, wet floor.
Then the camera ran out of film and enough
was enough.
“And she hear that and she just like freaked.
She just said hey man, we are not animals.
I don’t know what you are doing here but
we are not animals.”
After leaving the set, she eventually calmed
down and returned.
Carl Weathers in Rocky IV
A big part of the fourth Rocky movie involves
Rocky's mentor, Apollo Creed, staging a comeback.
Played by former NFL linebacker Carl Weathers,
Creed gets roughed up in the ring pretty bad
by Communist pugilist Ivan Drago, played by
Dolph Lundgren.
But one of the boxing scenes got a little
too real when Lundgren threw Weathers into
a corner, causing Weathers to break character
and throw a real punch.
Lundgren responded in kind, knocking Weathers
out.
When he regained consciousness, he quit the
movie and sent production into limbo for four
days.
That's when Sylvester Stallone finally convinced
Weathers to return.
Tippi Hedren in The Birds
Alfred Hitchcock had a reputation for being
unkind to actresses, but Tippi Hedren signed
on to 1963's The Birds under the guarantee
that she'd only be attacked with mechanical
birds during the film's climactic scene.
But Hitchcock is the king of twists, and he
wanted Hedren's terror to feel real, so he
instructed crew members to throw real, live
birds at her.
This real-life game of Angry Birds went on
for five full days and Hedren had a breakdown
when it was over.
She only finished the movie when a doctor
ordered Hitchcock to give her a week off to
recover.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
scene would have made you quit...